donc moi en fait je vois qui sait la
table ronde s'est rallongée donc j'ai
pas vraiment calibré pour si peu de
temps mon j'essaierai de le faire assez
vite
donc moi je vais vous donner des
informations de cadrage statistiques non
pas sur les flux parce que bon ça vous
avez peut-être un peu plus
d'informations et sur la réalité
actuelle
finalement personne ne sait vraiment ce
dont certains qu'il s'agit en termes de
masse mais essayez de ne vous donnez un
cadrage avec un aspect rétrospectif
alors bon vous savez souvent on parle
ans pour donner une idée de la faiblesse
de la migration en france du solde
migratoire de la france qui est un très
mauvais outils j'ai même pas besoin de
faire des signes c'est formidable qui
est un très mauvais outils puisque ça
mélange en fait des mouvements divers
qui sont les mouvements des natifs et
des immigrés et quand on essaie de faire
le départ entre les deux que j'ai fait
en estimation vous voyez que en fait on
a environ 240 milles
immigré en solde migratoire c'est à dire
entre émoi sortie chaque année est ce
que tu as vous impressionner sans doute
aussi c'est le solde migratoire négatif
des natifs qui en valeur absolue du chat
croit tous les ans alors on peut aussi
avoir une idée des flux à travers la
l'évolution de la population immigrée
mon qui vous savez et composé
d'étrangers venus en france quelle que
soit leur nationalité actuelle est donc
par cette une accumulation de stocks qui
donne une image des flux donc vous avez
ici l'évolution au fil des recensements
et est ce que vous pouvez voir c'est que
on a après environ 25 ans de calme
migratoire relative terminator on a une
nouvelle vague migratoire qui se
déclenchait que les années 2000 et qui
est d'ampleur équivalente à celle qu'on
a eu pendant les trente glorieuses
puisque la population immigrée a atteint
son maximum un maximum jamais connu
jusque là qui est de 88 8% en 2012 alors
le juge dit 2012
sachez que en statistiques on a toujours
un énorme retard par rapport à
l'actualité a aujourd'hui on peut pas
avoir deux chiffres sur la situation en
mais évidemment la population immigrée
c'est un outil limité pour donner une
idée de l'effet démographique des
migrations puisque vous avez des enfants
qui naissent en france et des enfants
qui n'auraient pas vu le jour évidemment
s'il n'y avait pas eu ces migrations
donc pour en avoir une idée il faut
mesurer l'apport démographique de
l'immigration et c'est ce que j'ai fait
je sais pas si on y est déjà oui c'est
formidable
donc c'est ce que j'ai fait j'ai estimé
le poids démographique de l'immigration
depuis 1960 deux reprises en 99 et en
2011 et donc vous pouvez distinguer un
apport direct qui est un apport en
migrant est un apport à direct en
essence eweek au total sans immigration
la france dont on compterait compterait
aujourd'hui enfin en 2011 9 7 millions
d'habitants en moins soit
un peu plus de 15% de la population et
la croissance de la population aurait
été de moitié inférieur à ce qu'on a
connu
alors vous voyez qu'une grosse moitié de
cet apport est constituée d'immigrés
évidemment et si vous regardez les
évolutions vous voyez entre 99 et 2011
donc le nombre de d'immigrés à cet
affreux d'un million et demi en 12 ans
donc c'est un accroissement de 40 4% et
d'un million 800 personnes nées en
france ou à l'accroissement de 65% et
cet accroissement supplémentaire est
favorisée par le nouveau cycle
migratoires des années 2000 que vous
avez vu tout à l'heure sur la courbe
alors je passe un peu vite parce que je
sais que le temps nous est compté
si j'arrive pas à séparer mais feuilles
se finira par ses pairs alors donc on
peut décomposer
cet apport migratoire en 2011 par vagues
par vagues quasiment décennale donc vous
avez ça sur ce graphique en distinguant
la partie apport direct c'est-à-dire en
immigrés à partir pour un direct qui est
en jaune ici qui est un enfant né en
france
est ce que vous remarquez bon bien sûr
que j'ai eu un apport important pour la
décennie 70 ne voyez surtout que
l'apport des deux années récentes ça va
ça va ça va s'avérer très important
puis ce qui en fait il ne fait que
commencer notamment pour l'apport
indirects et puis bien sûr compte tenu
de la qualité vous imaginez bien que les
flux vont continuer à alimenter tout ça
alors on se demande souvent quel est
l'impact de tout ça sur la fécondité
française il faut savoir savoir que
l'impact est beaucoup plus fort sur les
naissances puisque sans immigration en
2010 on aurait eu 27 % d'essence en
moins en france que sur l'indicateur de
fécondité
c'est difficile à comprendre mais
l'indicateur de fécondité dont on vous
parle souvent les deux enfants par femme
à peu près qu'on a en france c'est un
indicateur très quantité ces indicateurs
est fait pour le pour réduire les effets
de structure s'était auparavant donc
comme on l'a vu faire une population
jeune
l'effet global sur l'indicateur est
relativement faible vous le voyez ici
puisqu'il est de 7% sans immigration
depuis 1960 on aurait eu un indicateur
de 1,86 au lieu de deux enfants alors on
peut aussi essayer de calculer la
population d'origine étrangère en france
c'est encore autre chose quand on
calcule l'apport démographique on se
fixe une période pour la population
d'origine étrangère on se fixe un nombre
de générations dont là je vous ai mis
dans ce tableau
l'estimation de la population étrangère
sur trois générations pour les moins de
60 ans donc comme vous le voyez donc on
en a environ 4 14 millions de parmi les
moins de 60 ans qui sont d'origine
étrangère sur trois générations
c'est-à-dire qu'ils sont immigrés ont au
moins un parent immigré ou au moins un
grand parent immigré donc 14 millions
sur 48 millions ça fait près de 30 %
donc des personnes de moins de 60 ans et
comme vous le voyez là l'europe est en
train de devenir minoritaires
on le voit pas on voit on voit aussi si
vous voulez que cette prise en compte
sur plusieurs générations réintroduit la
dimension historique
si vous voyez par exemple la population
on a sauté c'est bon je passe
non c'est pas tout à fait ça avant ça
fait donc en fait on l'a vu sur la
population d'origine polonaise puisque
si vous prenez les immigrés y en a
quasiment pas aujourd'hui et si vous
regardez sur trois générations la 630
mille personnes et qui sont avant tout
des petits enfants d'immigrés polonais
donc alors je pensais ce cas là on est
revenu donc vous voyez que la domination
d origine européenne est en train de
céder la place à l'afrique d'abord ayant
parti à l'asie et que c'est de ce côté
là que viendront les
l'immigration futur alors si on passe à
l'histoire a maintenant vous avez une
vue plus nette de la manière dont se
répartissent les origines en fonction de
la génération si vous voyez chez les
immigrés il ya plus beaucoup d'européens
comme pour les voir chez les enfants
d'immigrés non plus mais ils sont très
largement c'est toute la partie en bleu
un pour les européens ils sont largement
majoritaires puisque ces trois quarts à
peu près chez les petits enfants
alors on peut essayer de voir ce que ça
donne au niveau des territoires
alors si on voulait avoir l'information
équivalente à celle que je vous ai
montré dans le tableau sur les
territoires il faudrait consentir à
demander un certain nombre de choses
dans les enquêtes annuelles de
recensement et notamment il faudrait
demander le pays de naissance et la
nationalité de naissance des parents
mais en fait j'ai trouvé un substitut
avec bernard aubry à strasbourg en en
regardant ce qui l'a été pour les jeunes
puisque les jeunes sont au foyer des
parents et au recensement et dans les
enquêtes annuelles de recensement au
dessous de 18 ans les ans les gens
vivent chez les enfants vivent chez
leurs parents
donc on peut savoir qui sont les enfants
d'immigrés non c'est ce que vous avez
sur la courbe bleue que ce graphique
alors avec des petits points verts qui
situe mes estimations de population
d'origine étrangère tout âge qui montre
que ces estimations sont dans les clous
est ce que vous voyez par rapport à
l'évolution en rouge de la population
immigrée c'est que pendant la période de
stagnation migratoire de 75 à 99
en gros je veux dire la populace
jeunesse d'origine étrangère a continué
d'augmenter
avec un ralentissement pendant les
années 90 et après la pointe que vous
voyez ici
alors alors c'est aussi on regarde
maintenant quelles sont les les
évolutions par origine alors que là il
ya eu des transformations très
importante ça c'est france entière mais
j'aurais pu vous montrer tout un tas de
deux graphiques pour des villes comme
grigny ou des européens y en a plus du
tout on vous avez l'évolution de la
composition de ces jeunes d'origine
étrangère avec la partie bleue
européenne qui diminue énormément au
profit du maghreb l'afrique et une
partie de l'asie
alors ce qu'il faut savoir c'est donc en
bon ça veut peut-être vous le dis vous
l'ignorez mais les régions les endroits
où cette populace est jeunesse d'origine
étrangère c'est être que le plus c'est
un grand quart ouest dans la france
comprenant l'île de france
alors évidemment ça n'a pas encore
beaucoup d'impact au niveau des régions
mais ça a un impact au niveau des villes
c'est ce que je vous montrerai tout à
l'heure avec blois donc d'en lancer dans
ce grand kar'ouest la jeunesse d'origine
étrangère a été multiplié par 2,5 en un
peu moins de 40 ans alors ça augmente et
en bretagne dans les pays de loire où
cette proportion de jeunes d'origine
étrangère était très faible au début de
la fin des années 60 alors bon les
régions où cette proportion attend au
moins autant au moins 20% sont l'île de
france l'alsace paca rhône-alpes
mais dans ces deux régions il faut
savoir que c'est un phénomène ancien
puisque si on prend cette proportion de
jeunes d'origine étrangère
elle était déjà de 23% en 1968 elle est
de 22% en 2011
donc c'est pas les régions ça s'est
fortement accrue alors évidemment
l'immigration et ses effets
démographiques sens
un phénomène essentiellement urbain qui
touche les petites communes qui touche
pelé alors je ne sais pas j'avais un
graphique il est plus voilà non alors
avant avant peut-être on va revenir à la
la la donc là vous avez une vision de
l'évolution de la proportion de jeunes
d'origine étrangère dans un certain
nombre de communes d'île de france
bon les noms vous disent bien évidemment
quelque chose puisque vous avez toutes
les communes que vous connaissez avec le
top à petit sous bois si je puis dire et
alors vous avez des communes où ça s'est
stabilisé très haut comme clichy sous
bois on est autour de 80% depuis
quelques années et des communes où ça
continue d'augmenter
comme à la courneuve bondi sevran evry
drancy au ris orangis et en
seine-saint-denis globalement vous avez
60 % des jeunes qui sont d'origine
étrangère en 2000 en 2011
non comme je vous le disais c'est à fait
domaine essentiellement urbain à vous
avez une courbe que moi je veux j'aime
beaucoup me manquer peut-être un peu
difficile à comprendre vous avez donc
l'évolution en fonction de la taille des
communes en abscisse de la proportion de
jeunes d'origine étrangère et chaque
chacune des courbes représentent une
année donc ce que l'on voit sur ce
graphique c'est l'augmentation
absolument très importante de la
proportion de jeunes d'origine étrangère
dans les villes entre 30000 et 100000
habitants et vous voyez que dans les
communes de moins de 10000 habitants il
s'est absolument rien passé puisqu'on
est on est à peu près au même niveau
c'est ce c'est cette partie où il n'ya
pas de distinction que vous voyez là
l'espèce de bras que vous avez là merci
madame
pardonnez moi de vous deux vous
interromps c'est extrêmement intéressant
et très précis est ce que vous pourriez
en tout cas moi je pense ça
m'intéresserait nous donner en global
sur l'ensemble de la population qui
réside aujourd'hui en france
à l'instant t le nombre de personnes de
nationalité étrangère et le nombre de
personnes immigrées sur l'ensemble de la
population qui alors
autant d'erreurs ça ça doit être 3
millions 1,8 pour les étrangers et c5
que 5 millions 6 pour les immigrés dont
les vêtements
moi j'ai essayé de dépasser ça parce que
ce que je veux montrer ses les élever
c'est les effets démographiques au
niveau des enfants donc si vous voulez
si on veut regarder ça il faut générer
il faut pas raisonner sur le nombre des
étrangers il faut raisonner par
génération il ya des gens qui arrivent
vous avez les immigrés et des ans des
générations d'enfants qui naissent
derrière donc c'est ça qu'il faut
regarder et c'est ce qui donne ce que
vous avez vu tout à l'heure les 14
millions de jeunes de moins de soixante
de personnes de moins de 60 ans qui sont
d'origine étrangère soit près de 30%
voilà donc
alors il faudrait peut-être sortir un
peu d'île de france parce que je vous le
disais tout à l'heure il ya eu des
choses qui sont passés dans les grandes
villes du grand quart ouest de la france
et sur ce graphique vous avez
l'évolution de troisvilles blois
poitiers et limoges par rapport à nos
grandes villes françaises paris lyon
marseille
est ce que vous voyez là dessus c'est
que c'est dans ces trois villes en
proportion de jeunes d'origine étrangère
on en est arrivé au même endroit ou même
on a dépassé pour blois est aujourd'hui
au dessus de paris en proportion de
jeunes d'origine étrangère
et quand on regarde plus plus
spécifiquement
blois et paris sur le prochain graphique
en proportion de jeunes d'origine non
européenne
donc vous vous avez paris en bleu et
vous avez blois envers envoyé ce qui la
manière dont ça a changé
donc c'est pas seulement dans la région
parisienne qui se passe des choses se
passent aussi des choses dans nos
grandes villes de l'ouest et je vais
terminer donc sur blois
vous avez sur ce graphique la proportion
de jeunes d'origine étrangère sur un
certain nombre des dernières années à
blois par iris de recensement donc vous
voyez que bon ça sale allures de
certaines villes de la région d'île de
france peut-être en un peu moins puisque
mais vous avez un indicateur de
dissimuler rites et qui équivalent ici à
celui qu'ont à mantes-la-jolie
l'indicateur de 10 similarités c'est
l'écart qu'on a entre la distribution
ici des jeunes d'origine étrangère note
européennes par rapport aux autres
jeunes
c'est à dire cet indicateur normalement
devrait être égal à zéro si vous aviez
dans chaque partie de la ville
la même composition et il est à 0,44 ici
à peu près comme à mantes-la-jolie vous
voyez qu'il ya un secteur qui c'est un
quartier qui s'appelle le quartier de
ne croire l'approchent vallier qui est
alors vous avez en bleu la partie centre
ville de blois tous les chiffres en bleu
c'est la partie centre ville de blois où
vous voyez que c'est des chiffres qui
sont inférieures à 20 % à peu près
partout et d'ailleurs vous avez au
dessus un quartier nord avec un quart
avec un une zone à 78% qui est celui de
croix chevalier
donc voilà l'évolution et nous non mais
je voulais conclure en disant que le
discours qu'on entend aujourd'hui
suivant lequel l'immigration est faible
et est une erreur puisque vous l'avez vu
nous avons aujourd'hui ainsi que
migratoires qui est équivalent en rythme
d'accroissement à celui des trente
glorieuses
donc nous ne sommes pas sans nous ne
sommes pas sortis de l'histoire
migratoire contrairement à ce qu'on
entend régulièrement et nous avons des
problèmes de concentration très
important et si vous voulez pouvoir les
mesurer
il faut consentir à demander un certain
nombre de choses et notamment pays n'ait
changé nationalité de naissance des
parents dans les enquêtes annuelles de
recensement
l'insee ne le fera pas sans une pression
politique importante et même je dirais
sans un consensus politique sur les deux
parties alors je voudrais juste terminée
par une remarque par rapport à ce que
dit monsieur lellouche
ça n'est pas giscard d'estaing qui a
inventé regroupement familial c'est pas
76 ans âge et c'est de divertir à faire
passer l'information
mais ce que giscard a fait à cette
époque là
en fait il a demandé l'arrêt total des
flux la décision a été contestée au
conseil d'état sur la question du
regroupement familial donc il a dû
réintroduire le regroupement familial
sur injonction du conseil d'état et
c'est là où il a mis des critères
deux logements de ressources etc pour le
regroupement familial mais c'est pas une
invention d'une longue ou moins
familiale y en a toujours eu et il de
malheureuse qu'il a essayé de faire
c'est de l'arrêter 74 n'en fait-elle bon
merci en tout cas madame